okay so after the March during the March
before the March this thing is just
becoming more and more political as you
said you guys are getting up there and
you want to you know sort of have your
moment but there are certain issues you
don't understand where politicians
reaching out to you I know that you know
Kyle cashew has talked to Marco Rubio a
couple of times
I mean how deep did this go in terms of
reaching every part of American society
sure we am we reached out to a lot of
people and a lot of people reached out
to us there were a lot of conservatives
that we were speaking to about the issue
I have a couple friends who went to gun
groups to talk about it sat down with
some very big gun advocates in their
areas not really in the country but
notable where they were to talk about
the issue and the I know that the rest
of my group was really interested in
opening up and talking about this again
I was the shady one in March for our
lives
I wanted to stir some [ __ ] you know I
wanted to cause trouble I wanted to make
I wanted to own the Conservatives the
same way a lot of conservatives want to
own the lives I mean that's what it's
about right now people people play games
where they're trying to one-up each
other and you know I just I was trying
to do that I was trying to make
politicians I didn't like look bad as
opposed to say what can we do yeah when
I went up there and I was we're focused
or anyone saying you know maybe he's up
on Twitter or like you know just just
because you're gonna get no matter what
even if everything you said was
factually right and came from the right
place and all that just the amount of
hate you're gonna get while you're still
young person warning so cannot be fun
my mom is her sole existence in the
world is to make everybody in the world
happy and love each other so she said to
me be nice and loving my dad who is a
bit of a political advocate himself
agrees with me on a lot of things and
sometimes he would tell me to ease up
sometimes he would tell me to you know
be a little bit rougher but he also said
and and this is why I think my parenting
from my mom stepdad dad stepmom was so
great was they said do what you think is
right and don't let people put their
hope
you and I did I let I let people
manipulate me a bit because I I thought
that they were kindred spirits
but you know my parent I'm lucky enough
to have parents who say believe what you
believe if I might you know my parents
are all liberal but if I came home and
said I'm if I came home with a Trump
2020 hat which I do not expect to do
unless some drastic change happens in my
life yeah although I know you're not
thrilled with the Democrats at the
moment I'm not thrilled the Democrats at
the moment but I'm not thrilled with
Democrats at the moment because they're
not being good Democrats not because
they're Democrats mm-hmm but we will get
to that I am but if I came home and I
told my parents that I would vote for
the opposite of what they would vote for
they would say if you're doing it
because you think it's right you're
gonna do it and I'm very grateful for
that
yeah so where do you stand on gun
control generally because I think what
happened was they at the event at March
for our lives there were a lot of people
getting up there and they were saying
things that implied and I think this is
the way a lot of people on the right
took it it's not about sensible gun
control this is ultimately about taking
away all the guns and that of course is
the fear of most of the people on the
right and there were a couple of the
students there was one young girl I
don't remember who said we're gonna
start with bump stocks but we're coming
for all the guns or something to that
effect and that that feeds right into
the people on the right who go alright
well now we're not gonna talk you got
gonna negotiate who like better laws you
guys are Mao Zedong exactly and then
because of that then the people on the
left and all you guys go well alright
see now they don't want to talk at all
so we're not going to talk and then you
end up sort of exactly where we're at at
the moment
it's and this is if somebody told me
this the other day it's a brilliant
point the left and the right attack each
other's worst arguments mmm-hmm and that
does nothing for us but when it comes to
my personal stance on guns there's so
there are some differing opinions
amongst my friends from ours for our
lives but we all we all agree with some
similar things personally I think that
as long as people who are responsible
can carry concealed firearms
particularly handguns in the country in
many situations the country's a safer
place I also think that there is not a
strong vetting process for people to
purchase these firearms and a lot of
people just get guns and a lot of these
people are not the good guy with the gun
because I think the good guy with the
gun argument is just a hasty
I understand it in some ways because I
intended to concealed-carry when I'm an
adult because I intend to have a family
and I intend to shoot anybody who tries
to kill my family and I assume the VAT
even that position right there probably
puts you on the outs with a lot of a lot
of your crew well the outer inception
team you know we all respect each others
opinions know somebody in March for our
lives and this is nobody in March for
our lives but if somebody said I want to
eliminate all guns I'd say okay well
let's talk about that mm-hmm so you know
my friends respect me for for what I
think and I respect them some it's
difficult it's a difficult thing to
respect people who disagree with you for
those things do you find that you know
guys and girls your age are able to have
these conversations without killing each
other there was a terrible choice of
words without shirt but about being at
each other's throats I think more than
adults are right now is that possible
because that seems to be a through line
with you that you're friends with a lot
of people of different opinions I think
we want to I think that a lot of people
who want to aren't taking the right
steps because they're saying yes we can
we can come to some common ground if you
agree with me and there's a there's a
want out there and that's something I'm
really interested in because I come from
a generation that I believe puts
principles and morals over money and
political victories and I think that
we've actually got a bright future now
people will call me an insane Bobby
Kennedy [ __ ] per se that we have a
bright future but I think we do I think
we need to distinct on verse a ssin I
have a lot of friends who who before
seven months ago I would have thought
were racist sexist bigoted homophobes
who want the country to explode and want
to destroy everybody who isn't exactly
like them and then I learned maybe
that's not the case mm-hmm and I have a
lot of friends who would have thought
that I was some leftist beta [ __ ] shill
who wanted who wanted the Communists to
take everybody's guns and kill him and
then they learn maybe that's not the
case I think our generation really is
moving in a good direction when it comes
to smart conversations I just think we
need a bit of a social revolution
they're not a huge social revolution I
love social revolutions this isn't that
a big revolutions cool it beetles you
don't think we're late Miz level yet
we're not I guess we're not hearing the
people sing the song of Angry Men yet
yeah but we we need some we need him we
need a movement towards respecting each
other because look before all this if I
could have gotten rid of the right I
would have and I know people who would
have gone rid of the left if they could
have but it's not gonna happen the
parties might evolve over time
I mean the parties are the parties are
flipping in a lot of ways well think
about this the party of Lincoln is the
only party that currently not the
Democrat there are some Democrats who
are like this but the majority of people
who are running as admitted white
supremacists are part of the party of
Lincoln mm-hmm so a lot of a lot of
switches happen there I mean you've got
some really awful rhetoric out there
from folks like Candace Owens who will
say we'll talk about the Left plantation
look I think identity politics are
dangerous but calling saying that the
real racists are the Democrats is a
hasty generalization I think that I
think there's actually some truth to it
well there's a difference between the
the Liberals and the left mm-hmm
well you're speaking my language
you can't pigeonhole them together
spigen all the right word for that yeah
okay you can't page him home together
I'm a liberal but I think that all men
and women are created equal and need to
be respected equally whereas people
farther to the left will say as a white
cisgender heterosexual male I don't have
the right to say any of that
look you a friend of mine Michael
Skolnik who I've worked with before said
something to me that I really
appreciated which was you can't judge
somebody by the hand they're dealt you
judge them by how they elect to play
that hand mm-hmm people farther to the
left will judge me by the hand I'm dealt
I grew up in a pretty well-off family I
had a pretty easy childhood I could have
walked around my neighborhood without
fearing death which is something that
some of my friends I made in Chicago
were not able to have but they'll say
that my opinion is less valid than
anybody's because I don't deal with the
struggles they do I have an incredible
amount of empathy for people who are not
as privileged as I am I believe the
white privilege exists I don't believe
it's as systemic or
or really structural as people say it is
I don't think the government exists to
oppress people but white privilege I
believe exists I believe that there are
certain situations where I will be where
I will be in a better place because I'm
a white cisgender heterosexual male
again it's not this large oppressive
force that people treat it like but it's
something we need to address and that's
that's the real thing I'm talking about
recently which is we can find common
ground on these issues and not try to
push each other away because in my view
in my view white privilege exists and
people will say well no because in many
situations on the SAT African American
students were given points and Asian
students were were deducted points and
and that proves that that well I got
myself yeah we don't have to go too far
down down that road because we could
have a whole other conversation on that
because I actually don't agree with you
on that but but that's the point of this
yeah that's the point and I'm still
learning you're still learning and it's
kind of a beautiful thing I'm 17 I can
hardly smell my expertise yet and that's
actually the point of the new podcast
I'm putting out yeah pretty soon it's
called Cameron knows nothing do you
watch Game of Thrones I do
lookyou great told me yeah and it's true
I you know I have my own personal views
on abortion I actually I watched a video
of yours you and I have this pretty much
the same exact view I'm a twenty weeks
guy mm-hmm
but I also have not taken enough science
classes I also do not have not conversed
with enough women who have had abortions
my opinions mean jack [ __ ] but I'm
allowed to have them you know it's I'm a
17 year old boy so there's only so much
I could truly say about pro-life or
pro-choice but I'm allowed to say it
yeah and you know in Cameron knows
nothing I'm gonna tell you guys what I
think but it doesn't mean it's right you
know where do you think that attitude
comes from within you because it seems
to me that I think a lot of what's
happening right now is I see adults that
are now afraid to say what they think
and you know they think that the mobs
gonna come after them which is
completely legit they think it might
hurt their job opportunity or things
like that yeah the mob whichever
whichever
right I mean I think but we see boycotts
on both sides and I think a lot of
misguided anger off and but I think most
people need a little bit more of what
you just did there which is I just am
what I am
you know maybe convince me of some other
stuff but I'm trying to learn here I
don't want to hurt anybody you know I
want the government to crackdown on guns
that doesn't mean I want the government
to oppress you I believe that there's a
certain amount of time somebody you
should have access to an abortion and I
think that abortion should be more
accessible just for a certain amount of
time but I don't want to kill babies and
I don't want to oppress women I want the
world to be a better place you want the
world to be a better place I don't know
about about you know anybody up in the
booth but they seem really nice yeah
they're pretty good yeah yeah Todd
McFarlane I hand selected these people
exactly Todd McFarlane wants the world
to be a better place David hog wants the
world to be a better place
Jordan Peterson wants the world we all
pretty much all of us do I'm actually
glad you mentioned Jordan Peterson
because you know I'm on tour with him
right now and one of the things that I
find is first of I meet a ton of people
your age I'd say the bulk of the people
that are coming there are young people
probably probably right around your age
seventeen eighteen into into they're
probably early 30s and it's male/female
gay straight black white the whole thing
but it's very obvious to me that he's
providing some level of guidance that
somehow it seems that your generation
kind of missed now it sounds like you're
your folks are pretty great in your
extended family and all that but do you
sense that there is some missing piece
here that partly I don't know that
there's like some I discussed this last
week with Peter teal that there was some
disconnect between the baby boomers my
parents age and that that my guys the
Gen X people we never had our moment or
something and then we've sort of handed
it off to you guys the Millennials and
their genetics
I'm genetics oh I'm Jed Z actually
you're Wow
whether those are three or four years
older than I am all right oh man I don't
but that we handed it off to the to the
generation of people who grew up with
with cell phones immediate access to
knowledge response are the best and
worst thing to ever happen to us yeah if
I wanted to get to a hospital I can get
to a hospital much easier with a cell
phone if I want to look up a fact
forgetting the fact that facts are
difficult right now active facts are
difficult to find regret is if they you
know I can do it but also I before all
of this I was very very obsessed with my
own image not because I thought I had a
good one but because I wanted it to be
good mm-hmm
I was posting things online because I
wanted people to think I had a cool life
I mean I did I had a great life but I I
wanted people to know that and and it
the hyper connectivity of social media
which is a term I stole from many been
plat interviews where he's talking about
his musical do you Evan Hanson I don't
want him to see this and think I'm
stealing for the hyper-connectivity of
social media is um
is is a good and bad thing but I think
the problem here and I think that you
know folks like Jordan I'm a big fan of
Jordan I'm a big fan of yours don't get
it be good people people like you guys
one of the things that you advocate for
is is conversation and people on the
right young people on the right that I
know and I'm friends with they want to
own the lips this is all about proving
them wrong and saying like facts don't
care about your feelings I agree facts
by definition don't care about your
feelings but there's also logic which is
kind of the middle between the two
really and that's the interpretation and
the insight and the fact where you know
if we if we only based everything in
facts which a lot of young people on the
right do we're just talking about the
past you can't look at the future and
you can assess facts but a lot of a lot
of young people on the right want to
prove people wrong and a lot of young
people on the left I've seen want to
want to make people want to make people
who disagree with them look worse it's
all about making the other look worse
the right wants to show that the left is
a bunch of commies and left wants to
show that the rights a bunch of fascists
and that's a waste of time that is a
that is what is harming our country
right now I think Donald Trump's
rhetoric is dangerous and harms our
country but Trump is is the there's a
symptom of something greater like
President Obama said when he made his
return that made all of my liberal
friends think Jesus came back which is
you know Trump Trump is the result of a
country where the people who love Trump
are loving it more than ever and the
people who hate Trump are hating it more
than ever because we are divided mm-hmm
you know with our rhetoric is is driving
these driving everybody in different
directions that's why you see the rise
of democratic socialism and that's why
you see the rise of
more and more people coming out and
saying things that are stupid because
they have the first man right to do it
look if you say something I don't like I
will defend it with my life I will
defend with my life you're right to say
it but people are mixing being not PC
and being a jerk and and right now we're
driving apart we need to come together
stop attacking each other both sides are
equally as guilty certain sides in
certain situations are obviously guilty
everybody yeah it it's it's it's it's
[ __ ]
so do you sense a little more
flexibility on the ability to talk to
people on the right than on the left
because you know that that's been a sort
of big part of what's going on with me
like I get invited to go to these
conservative things in turning-point USA
and I talk about being gay married and
I'm pro-choice and against the death
penalty and all of these things that are
thought of as leftist things but they
invite me we have a great time I take a
zillion selfies with the kids after and
all that stuff where there doesn't seem
to be that flexibility over there now I
get I don't want to harp on this because
I get your greater point which is we got
to get past this sure but it's where
it's what I am
I do see something on one side
especially with young people that has
become more corroded I would say then on
the others here's what I'll say I say
the left cares too much about people and
the right doesn't care enough and I'll
tell you what I mean because they're
they're equally as wrong here young
people on the right will attack you with
facts and in in either positive or
negative ways and they're open a
conversation very often I believe
because they want to prove you wrong
that's what I've seen from that like
that's not a fact it's an opinion
whereas people on the Left want to
accommodate for everybody so much that
if you say anything negative about
anybody that they agree with they jump
to their defense so I'll bring up the
Israel argument which is an argument
that I don't know enough about to form
an opinion I truly do not yeah but if
you are propel that sounds like pretty
much everybody exactly being Pro
Palestine doesn't mean you hate the Jews
necessarily and being pro-israel doesn't
mean that you hate everybody
you hate Palestinians but I'll talk to
people on the right and they'll they'll
be happier to talk about it than people
on the left but the second I say that
you know Palestine should have land
which again I don't
I don't have a firm opinion on mm-hmm
they'll say do but you're Jewish how
could you say that I'll say because
people are people and then I'll talk to
people on the left about it and I'll say
there's a lot of concerns of terror and
they'll say don't you dare call
everybody the everybody who's
Palestinian a terrorist and on both
sides or do so so yes I think the right
is more open to conversation but I think
that more people on the right are trying
to Lou you into a cave where they could
prove you wrong I don't want to be
proven right or wrong right now I want
to discuss because my opinions on things
have changed my opinions really are not
taking a 180 I have all my opinions but
my opinion on opinions is changing
that's that's the most important thing
I'd like to highlight here you know if
I'm talk is to think that and we've
talked about the sights to think that if
you didn't agree with me you've hated me
know I've learned a different thing and
I'm not and what what I'm advocating for
now is I'm not asking people to change
their perspectives I'm asking people to
stop having your feet so firmly on the
ground
when your child because I'm a child you
know I can't rent a car I can't smoke a
cigarette nor do I intend to but at the
end of the day I can't tell you about I
can't tell you with authority about
economics I can't tell you what I think
I haven't taken an econ class or a
finance class and we need it
you're already doing better than most
experts on CNN I think people on the
left and the right and you just need to
realize that facts are facts feelings
are feelings logic is logic but the more
and more we try to prove each other
wrong the less progress we're gonna make
because I have had the mindset that's
why I understand it I've had the mindset
where all I wanted to do was just own
the Conservatives and I know people who
have had the mindset where all they
wanted to his own the libs yeah and by
the way I know you're not just saying
this because Kyle cashew of who I've
gotten to know well who falls off and on
the other side of this in you he's now
working with turning-point and he's you
know trying to strengthen the Second
Amendment and all sorts of other things
you guys are friends and you guys are
still able to talk about these things
and we you know I had originally said
maybe we could get both you guys in here
but we thought this would be a good
opportunity just to let you do
your thing and I'll have kai-lan
separately but you guys are despite your
differences you're able to talk a lot of
things Kyle does I don't like a lot of
almost everything he says I disagree but
there are some things he says that I
think are inappropriate I've said some
inappropriate stuff and and you know I
understand it if you don't agree with me
and you want to come out and speak I I'm
proud that I was able to speak after the
shooting and Kyle did too so I haven't
understood deep understanding of his
position so beyond the podcast and I
will give you my word that I will do the
podcast oh please yeah well you asked me
to do it the email was can you do my
yeah I'm more than happy to do it we'll
make that happen what what do you want
to do well have you have you really been
able to think about it at this point I
know it's sort of an annoying question
to ask a young person no I mean you know
I can't tell you what college I want to
go to I can't tell you where I want to
be in 50 years but I could tell you that
right now I want to dedicate my time to
do and what I think is the best thing I
could do with my platform because I have
a large platform for all the worst
reasons and with great platform comes
great responsibility
writer man exactly Uncle Ben says that I
believe it was Uncle Ben yeah but when
you say Uncle been on this show people
might be like kindly talking about
Benjamin Parker yeah and I have a
responsibility to do what I think is
right and what I think is right is
advocating for what I believe in but
also making sure that the conversation
is mended and healed because who better
than the people who are about to become
adults to try and make sure that our
next generation of adults knows how to
work together I mean you got Nelson and
Rubio in Florida I'll give you a great
example
Nelson Rubio have passed some great
bills together because Nelson Rubio
don't see idea.i to I but they are able
to put their differences aside they get
along and I want more of that
yeah well man I know a lot of people are
worried about the future but I mean it's
clear to me that your future is bright
and if we can hand it over if we can
hand it over to people like you will be
alright because this is this is
everything that I've been trying to do
here I think it's summed up in the way
they
you're trying to go forward with life
it's pretty awesome really it's
inspiring
I appreciate that let me ask you
something yes your show I'm gonna bring
us why you're flippin emotions you are
in theater all right exactly
yeah so Spock so what what are the
qualities you are looking for in a
candidate if you are going to vote for
them over president Trump at 2020 oh man
you're really putting me on the spot
here yeah this is my show look I've said
this before but it seems to me that
unfortunately the Democratic Socialist
wing of the Democrats has gone really
far left I mean look the word socialist
is in the is in the title now and purged
right I guess they're being honest for
what they are and they're fighting for
what they believe in I happen to
disagree with virtually all of it but
that they're doing that they've
basically purged what I think are the
the remaining liberals as you said
classical liberals before and I think
unfortunately that leaves a lot of us
it's why people watch my show because
I've just been honest about what I see
here that leaves a lot of us suddenly
with allies in places that we didn't
think we were gonna have allies and it's
sort of unfortunate in one way because
you want to always think that you can
sort of stay home and fix things got a
pebble but at the moment I find my
allies have certainly are libertarians
on the right I think I can you know be
allies in a lot of ways with ben shapiro
even though we have differences on the
margins like with abortion and some of
that other stuff but i don't see at the
moment one from when we're taping this
right now i just don't see any hope in
the short term for the democrats my hope
is that this thing implodes that they
get probably have to get crushed in the
midterms which is not looking likely but
that they get crushed in the midterms
and then they have a major course
adjustment where they go we've got to
return to liberalism sure and that is
the answer because I believe liberalism
is the answer I think it's the only
answer but if you know somebody that I
should be paying attention to let me
know because I don't see much you keep
in touch and
I'll send you some liberals oh yeah one
more thing I know we're bad on - yeah
what is your favorite musical and with
which musical character do you identify
the most oh man yeah really going for it
I'd rather do favorite superhero movie
you're saying but super movie let's go
to that well I was telling you during
the break that I I mean I really thought
infinity war was spectacular I think it
was just done right Loki has to be dead
though that's that's the key thing I
want but I here's the thing I love
Gamora I've she's amazing I know she's a
badass but if they bring her back which
they will bring her back she was killed
in the process of getting the soul stone
so they could say that once they destroy
the stones or what it however it may be
right they could bring her back and I it
will be nice to see her back because I
love her as an actress I love her
chemistry with everyone yeah but that
was a power for me you can't keep
killing people and bringing them back
that's why Loki has to be dead this time
which they basically made it sound like
yeah what infinity war did a good job
with you no I told Tony he's been in MCU
for what like 20 movies yeah and he
didn't die Gamora this is her third film
and I felt that yeah I felt that death I
hate I hate to tell you but she's well I
hate to tell you or whatever she's good
she's gonna be alive but putting that as
our audience the musical you know I'm
not a huge musical guy I'm not I know
you don't want to hear that as don't was
a theater guy no not a huge musical I
liked Mamma Mia we can we can find some
common get see that's what it's about
common ground exact listen man we could
have talked about Marvel movies and all
these other you gave me a lollipop
cultural references before we started
you have to you have to you know break
new ground and that's what I was trying
to do here that's what it's all about I
have no doubt you have a bright future
and you're probably gonna be president
is that where this is all leaving
president of Stoneman Douglas high
schools drama club no because my dear
friend she ran and she's doing a
phenomenal job that no guys follow
Cameron on Twitter it's Cameron
underscore Caskey
[Music]